[Music]
last time on the statue critic Z critic
was confronting the worst anime
adaptation of all time no the other one
there you go so shitty movie you think
you can piss off a legion of fans with
your misunderstanding of source material
if silence only enables your guiltiness
now I will show you the meaning of pain
you can't but it's evil alone Masako X
from team four star joins nostalgia
critics fight mask o X from team four
star you've come to join my fight I
totally just said that you need to
Dragon Ball fan to understand this
outrage what do you know about wrecking
ball that I don't cleansing
like hell we cut to the extreme like
shots to save on the animation and your
anger of this will be represented by
zoom out
combined with grunting and clenching
your teeth with your eye twitching grunt
nello
but you by doing the same move
repeatedly and you doing the same dust
repeatedly you fools are missing the
real enemy
little kuriboh comes to talk sense into
the feuding heroes so little kuriboh
you've come to talk sense to us the
buting heroes my just not here or get
out of here Yuki blow you're not even
from the right anime maybe but I'm smart
enough to know that while you two are
bitching like pansies your opponent is
building his power mic up she's going
stupid say it it's okay this Yugi last
ten minutes there's surprisingly little
fighting in the show it's mostly us
screaming while rocks rise up but he's
using his stupid Saiyan power to make
stupid people say his movie is good
what's impossible
just check out its critical score it's
over nine person what nine percent
there's no way that can be right can add
people who don't know the show we're
being duped into thinking it's good we
can't let it get away with that agree
let Dueling sides join forces just this
once once we mean probably many times
what
in a long line of botched live-action
anime adaptations Dragonball Evolution
is arguably the most infamous
for years I've gotten fan requests to
talk about this cinematic ball buster
but sadly even though I'm a fan of some
anime shows and films Dragonball is not
one I know a great deal about that's
where we come in masa collects from
Dragon Ball Z abridge and little kuriboh
from Yukio abridged that's right a
Japanese anime dubbed by Americans now
analyzed by two bricks it makes as much
sense as anything else in this movie the
Dragon Ball franchise is one of the most
popular animes ever made taking place in
a parallel dimension it follows the
adventures of Goku and his friends
defending earth against intergalactic
aliens androids and other various evils
who really like to yell with spin-offs
including Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball Z
Kai Dragon Ball GT and Dragon Ball super
there's over 700 episodes of this
franchise and it's still going so
naturally it made sense for Hollywood to
try and capitalize on it and make a
movie for Americans how did it go it
goes in the Shelby bed yes then this did
really bad fans of the show and
newcomers hated this adaptation claiming
it not only missed want Dragon Balls
about but dumbed it down so much that no
average moviegoer would be able to enjoy
it it's said by many to be the worst
anime adaptation of all time don't
believe me how many people thought the
low-budget sketch that we just did was
more faithful that sounds about right
so let's not put it off any longer let's
take a look at this Dragon Ball sock
with Dragonball Evolution I hope you're
ready for an intro that's front-loaded a
shit I think I don't know you know the
warlord named piccolo came from beyond
the stars a group of brave warriors
created the muscle ba
full enchantment that Wow both lost and
bored get used to that aided by his
disciple oozaru the evil pair brought
the human race to the brink of
annihilation okay shot in the dark a
great evil tried to take over is
defeated and now he's trying to come
back wow it's almost like you see the
movie at some point in your life enough
to know when to fast forward we see our
main character played by Justin Chatwin
named Goku um I don't know a ton about
the enemy but that doesn't look like a
Goku
well as a white man I'm offended you are
yes
stereotyping like that I for one embrace
culturally diverse names that in no way
raise any questions or seem distracting
wow I really didn't think this with the
angle you guys would lean of course John
shaft would be so much better if he was
called Akio Hashimoto James Bond would
be more culturally sensitive if he was
named Bubba gray Lee and Ariel from The
Little Mermaid would be lightyears ahead
of her time if she was called barber I
see what you're saying a rose by any
other name would smell as sweet but if
you named that rose shitty shitty ass
piss you might want to change something
Goku is trying his hardest to master his
epic no sweat this movie clearly
understands what to shoot in slow-mo as
his grandpa states what we know this
annotation took to heart first rule is
there are no rules well we've given an
excuse not to follow these first one to
touch the ground loses as the second
rule after the first rule of there being
no rules
Crouching Tiger not-so-hidden
green-screen
and now a brief recreation of the
audience reaction to this first two
minutes
[Music]
this movie does know the difference
between an anime and a Donald Duck
cartoon right slimy yet saving with
anger filled disappointment
next we'll fight without the wires next
time on Dragon Ball marionette so in the
original show Goku was a young naive
fighter obsessed with perfecting his
gift and honoring the art of combat
fighting when he needs to hear he's a
whiny little pissant who just wants to
be cool and get laid
anyway it's good she's feel like I'm
nothing grandpa she should better get
the girl to be fair though that is a lot
of episodes of a character's life to fit
into one movie don't worry that's why
there is the slumming it fairy what the
slumming it fairy she magically provides
stock lines when you don't want to put
real work into a character yeah what we
don't want to put any effort into one of
japan's most beloved characters but we
still want a paycheck for it can you
supply us with some dated angst yeah oh
here's a tired classic I'm different I'm
different here's one with no effort I
wanna explode I wanna explode and who
can forget the popular teach me to be
normal
teach me be normal oh and don't forget
what friends what friends we did it
we produced someone so special to so
many to someone not the least bit
special in any way yeah don't forget you
get stuck parental advice for no
additional Church oh she's right
including you're special you're special
normal is overrated normal is overrated
and have faith in who you are oh you are
Thanks slumming it fairy you took from
other source material even though we
have plenty of source material to
already take from whatever did I get
high on your couch curtains this is only
gonna get worse isn't it yes it is save
some room on that couch Goku's grandpa
gives him a present for his birthday a
Dragon Ball which when combined with the
other six will grant a perfect wish and
we know they never found because this
film is still here in all the world
there are only six others
- Shinto means four stars you know
something this film will never see
thanks grandpa
so the Dragon Ball universe that seemed
to magically take place in the past
present and future expanding the world
building possibilities of the
imagination is now just the future
apocalyptic utopium techno bland again
having not seen much of the anime I can
still pick up that the movies
environment looks practically nothing
like the show's environment even the
environment in the film is not very well
defined it would take a while to even
realize we were in the future unless we
were told this could be the set to any
random film we're with the show just one
image could tell you immediately you're
watching Dragon Ball yeah but at least
the film's bullies make me pancake oh hi
generic come on geek Oh show me what you
got yes you'll realize very quickly that
the facial expressions that Goku has
ranged from violent farting to try to
project himself off the ground farting
don't a lot of people do fart jokes when
talking about this movie didn't you hear
rule number one there are no rules
[Music]
next time on Dragon Ball Metamucil oh um
meanwhile on Bowser's airship a villain
named piccolo is wondering why being
hundreds of feet in the air gets him
surprisingly little wind resistance in
the show piccolo is complex and had
interesting reasons for why he wanted
ultimate power
he was so interesting that even his
offspring would eventually become
friends with our main hero here just a
colossal twat right he wants to take
over the world because you know evil and
stuff and sends out his minions to find
the Dragon Balls to achieve his goal do
you like my assassin uniform and make
sure you know that I oppressed
another batch we got a cut too horny
Goku
[Music]
to be fair Goku in the show was
awkwardly horny - yeah but he'd never
seen a girl before so he didn't know he
was horny does that make it better
better than this I'll agree to that yeah
what might our ancestors say about the
upcoming solar eclipse well my
grandfather would say beware the pneumix
mimics yeah they're an alien race that
nearly destroyed earth over 2,000 years
ago we have no idea how this future work
so we have no idea how crazy this is
supposed to sound oh let's hope it
doesn't happen again keep it in
Scientology but it looks like Goku's
help with the lockers might have earned
him some tail no actual tail that'd be
like the show like anyone would cast me
as a go coop
uh oh I mean uh yes that's my character
you should keep you know about ki just
because my name is Chi Chi doesn't make
me a complete idiot right yeah what I'm
having a party tonight at my house I'll
be there oh that's a pretty shot
well back to shit Beauty awaits
it's there a film theory that he's just
the pain in the ass he played in war the
world after the aliens invaded nobody
wasted any theories on this film Goku
sneaks out of his house to go to chi
Chi's party where the bullies who
literally have no reason to mock him
mock him I was invited I'm not looking
for any trouble I found you freaks
listen why don't you turn around walk
away no even know you were here J you
freak with your good looks and yet
yeah nice hair and your fancy clothes E
what are we doing I'm not doing that
the talks are gonna Rumble tonight
thank God we all know really bad kungfu
especially this guy how far away was
that punch
did he just slide across the car with
his head come on even crime wouldn't do
that
well the way is even in this no he's a
chef film should I be angry at that yeah
I'm really angry
so the original Goku who hated fighting
and only did it when he had to is now
tossing one-liners like an unfunny James
Bond and fart faces two nevertheless he
defeats the bullies and gets friendly
with chichi what happened your parents I
don't know but my grandpa said
everything will be explained to me when
I turn eighteen my grandpa's kind of a
dick but he might not get his wish as
grandpa is attacked by piccolo who is
literally dressed like a piccolo he
destroys the house because apparently
piccolo can do that now and Goku comes
home to his dying mentor by master roshi
in paozu now if you'll excuse me there's
a dead mentor a poker game with obi-wan
Kenobi Uncle Ben Dumbledore and Mickey I
need to attend in a better hurry
I hear get off my drop back briefly
after searching the house Goku finds I
think a second present he was going to
give him
even his dead grandpa laughs at how
stupid that looks but he quickly
discovers he's not alone where is it
I know it's here are you piccolo the
costings so bad she could be actually
this is bomba played by Emmy Rossum
singing no good they originally met when
Goku was a little boy but now in this
they're the same age it works because
wait no it doesn't if I wasn't Hickel oh
whatever that is I wouldn't tell you
somebody stole my promethium orb and I'm
here to get it back
you know this movie has enough
whitewashing do we really have to dub
wash too PhD in applied dynamics they're
gonna make me famous what a story mark
somebody hacked the vault killed the
guards and stole the Dragonball what is
this Spy Kids I've seen toy commercials
with more realistic technology this can
detect and locate the signature
wavelengths emitted by the dragonballs
thank God they talked about the
important stuff that really matters in
this film well you made a Dragonball
energy locator Dragonball energy DBE
catchy name it's okay okay we're gonna
get through this right give me the gun
okay you okay you don't get better than
last time yeah he's a big fan they
agreed to join forces to find the other
dragonballs and they ride on her my god
support levels are through the roof they
go to find Roshi as his grandpa
instructed and locate him in the house
from up
next time on Dragon Balls seriously
seriously
Goku wakes up Roshi and makes the sad
discovery the cherry on fat found a film
worse than Pirates three to appear in
CGI is atrocious
[Applause]
to be fair Chow Yun fat while certainly
different it's not that bad a choice for
this role he's a wisecracker a little
pervy and energetically full of himself
but then their scenes like this
my grandfather's dead it doesn't get rid
of the pain but it does make it hurt a
little less
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
his most heartfelt powerhouse
performance I will avenge him but before
he he died he asked me to find you what
do you think the directing for that
scene was like non-existent Roshi gives
them his Dragon Ball and says he'll join
them to find the others Jenner was fault
I would kick you to a secret place he
takes them to a training temple that
looks more like Mortal Kombat High
School where what a surprise
chichi happens to be training there
nobody at home knows this but I'm a
fighter too they just want to understand
what does that even mean fighting for
money fighting for justice fighting for
fun nothing else in this world makes
sense so why should this mean shit after
that seemingly pointless scene seemingly
entirely we fall down a hole and get
trapped by a guy named Yamcha I'd be so
grateful if you could just help me and
my friends out I'm gonna need some
payment payment let me try I'd be so
grateful if you would just help me and
my friends out just stick it over coz
after the Sun comes out it's gonna be
hot hot hot just because you can
improvise doesn't mean you should they
build a fire as it gets late in the
night and Roshi literally tells the same
story we heard in the opening but Bulma
finds out only now for some reason that
the Dragon Ball is buried beneath them
that's lucky
enough games why did he do that before
ass they offer to pay Yamcha fee helps
them dig which is weird because that
means they could have just paid him
before anyway how many how much did they
waste down there so digging through a
hole somehow leads them to the top of a
volcano
what piccolo sends his puppies I mean
minions to stop them in doing so though
he only provides a way for them to get
to the Dragon Ball our evil strategist
everybody who gets the ball but is
pretty easily defeated by Piccolo's
assassin only to have her easily
defeated a second later look at this he
talks in the next scene like he doesn't
even notice her there's this demon Oh
Cyril
he will kill you oh there's a lady - she
got a swing in just 20 round in case she
was supposed to be a powerful
second-in-command so chew the fat
harmony star surf ninja and Elijah
wooden all travel to the temple of
underappreciated ghostbusters how is my
favorite skeptic I need another
containment vessel I mean we saw what
happened to the last one
you don't yeah yeah yeah yeah so even
though in the show that focuses on
mastering energy here it's mastering
airbending they do not call it that oh
but they do the most basic of all the
airbending techniques do they know the
difference between animes non animes and
abominations of God I'm honestly
surprised Sailor Moon isn't in this next
time on Dragon Ball The Last Airbender
oh forget it
hey Kyle where you going get back here
you coward I'm sorry guys you know
Dragonball Evolution is one thing but
throwing Shyamalan in there - I still
have my shame - hold on - bastard you
never next time on Dragon Ball Z again
with this waifus funny by the way how in
the show Goku was a child prodigy and
here he can't even light a goddamn
candle well that's because he's not
properly horny baited everytime you
light a torch you get to take one
step closer to me no I swear that
happens to all guys it doesn't feel
right if it I must be missing something
you have to make every move your own
you've stolen from like a million other
films something has to be original he
finally gets it but Piccolo's has had
some breaks in disguises chichis
stealing the dragonballs Rossum has a
look that says Wow
how are the Ducks effects are way more
convincing right now he's alive but
barely Goku has a near acting experience
where he sees his grandpa and you know
it's not your time have faith in who you
are it's not your time cuckoo always
have faith in who you are he actually
says that why not just have him say
plenty of fish in the sea remember to
drink you milk
meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow
hashtag popular phrase grandma brings
Goku back to life because he's only half
dead and they go to stop piccolo after
apologizing to Ernie Hudson for having
him for only two minutes brain it is
enough to contain piccolo namaste it's
been three hours and make up for this
thankfully their color is
chitty-chitty-bang-bang and can fly fast
enough to stop Piccolo's monologuing
imagine being shackled so tightly that
every atom in your body stood compacted
with this Dragonball I take my vengeance
upon the earth you know just because
you're under acting is way better than
the overacting doesn't mean it's not
under acting they get there at the start
of the Eclipse and tried to stop him
from taking over the world look he even
has an outfit on it's totally Dragonball
now guys I will defeat asaru and I'm
here to destroy you
defeat oozaru people can barely act but
in a bizarre twist Goku it turns out is
Oh Zahraa turning into a monster
it'll be nice if someone prepared him
for that my grandpa said everything will
be explained to me when I turn 18 Goku
is a shell shell this is who you are the
thoughts faces must frou they have a
Dragonball don't make my voice sound
even more disinterested Goku kills Roshi
po remembers who he is and turns back
impossible something my grandfather
taught me first rule is always read the
script there are no rules then how is
that the first rule let's just dumb dick
alone Goku finally faced off and for a
movie adapted from a show known for its
fighting this fighting sucks some harsh
balls
Bible man had better effects look at
this most of the fighting is just Goku
trying not to get his ass kicked
no that's not true he hit him once twice
oh my god I think that's it one of the
most famous fighters in anime and he
gets two hits well look at it this way
we should just live here
Goku realizes he has to be both himself
and azar ooh whatever that means and he
unleashes the ultimate power that's
right the Kamehameha in the show this is
always the highlight an incredible
display of power blowing everyone
figuratively and literally away yeah I
think he turns into a screen saver
oh no he's turned into 3d pipes actually
can we just watch that they are more
convincing I truly believe that their
pipes the Eclipse wraps up but nothing
compares to the shade this movie has
given to the Dragon Ball franchise hey
now that Goku has the Dragon Balls and
has one perfect wish what's he gonna use
it on dragon the test of seven has been
fulfilled I compel you to come forth and
grab my wish not until you say like you
give a shit Christ the putrid pus looks
so fake you could have Sean Connery
voicing it give life to muten roshi
funny he could have used that wish to
grant world peace Oh bring back his
grandpa the person who raised him Oh
maybe bad the power to grant back anyone
he wants whenever he wants how long was
this journey they employ a time to talk
about this but the dragonballs are gone
and they have to find them again no no
as if this film didn't already shit
we've seen a million times but it's cool
because Goku reunites with chichi who
stayed behind while everyone else fought
yeah where was her lazy ass because
that's what Dragonball is all about
don't go punching Chi Chi's heel in
midair and just when you think it's over
well the pain never really stops critic
I know but in terms of the movies ending
it turns out they have a mid credit
stinger it's revealed that piccolo is
still alive and he's being tended to by
a woman okay that should only take 5
seconds to reveal they want well they do
apparently think that it is a big whoop
because they spend about a minute and a
half dragging this reveal out a minute
and a half
well the suspenseful build-up of picking
plants
[Music]
bringing the plants inside
putting the plants in the medicine
making the medicine oh yes
carrying the medicine down the hallway
taehui gallic die critic this is all
essential in delivering such a
powerhouse reveal bringing the medicine
into the room dabbing a cloth in the
medicine and then the reveal
[Music]
they're not happening sequels right next
time on Dragon Ball Z a cold day in hell
oh hey Kyle came back that's right and
only Ryu or Ryu or however you say his
name can save the day David Rob Bailey
you're not Kylie bear but I fooled you
for a minute didn't I subscribe to my
channel so that was Dragonball Evolution
whether you're an average movie goer or
a die-hard fan
it blows it's visually disjointed it has
little to no world building the acting
is awkward the effects are lame it's
pretty laughably bad fans that have
waited years for a faithful live-action
movie are gonna have to keep waiting
because this has no idea of what Dragon
Ball was about or what made it so
special it doesn't work in any way and
any newcomers that are introduced to
Dragon Ball this way risk losing a fan
for life it's just one big disrespectful
mess well I probably would have hated
the movie anyway but thank you guys so
much for showing me and how many
different levels I should hate it no
problem quitting my miserable pleasure
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I wait wait you
sure you guys don't want me to narrate
you out you know guys maybe I was
jumping the gun a little bit when I left
and like hey who the hell are you I'm
Kyle Hebert I'm gone for a minute and
you already get another Kyle a bear now
I'm sorry but he's a pretty good Kyle
thanks he was talking to me well there's
only one way to settle this
that's right Kyle a bear off what agree
you two will face off to see who's the
best narrator of Dragon Ball Z can you
win all right let's do this okay yeah
ready
Get Set guys it really is kind yes true
he was there first yeah good point cow
you win yes say what I've been establish
a critic I'm Massa COEX I'm little
kuriboh and avoid Dragonball Evolution
like the plague will go on reclaim his
former glory which was unceremoniously
squashed on DBZ will Goku be able to
close the hole in the ozone layer caused
by all the hairspray used in his super
saiyan doom and hawks keen find true
love on tinder when will mr. Satan join
the WWE become an honorary member of the
new day how much wood could a woodchuck
chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood
does the mainland Spain falls mainly on
the plain or just in Detroit
you
DBE catchy name
hello Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
American Refugee Committee this is an
international NGO that responds to
crisis and helps refugees build lives of
dignity and self-sufficiency they work
in 11 countries in Africa the Middle
East and Asia bringing more than 35
years of expertise and services such as
health and sanitation to empower of
refugees around the world refugees share
with them what they need and they work
together to create programs that make
the most sense for that particular
community pursuing new and better
solutions to enduring humanitarian
challenges by supporting and co-creating
with local organizations they've been
able to reach around the globe and reach
a unique and sustainable impact on
communities both their sight and their
YouTube channel show the incredible work
that they do and they even earned an A+
on charity watch org give them a look
and see how you can help these people
continue their amazing achievements
[Music]
you